nos encontramos en la calle que conduce
al edificio del gobierno esta noche
alrededor de las 5 de la mañana se han
producido nuevos estallidos hemos oído
las sirenas antiaéreas y luego una
estación fuerte en esa zona como pueden
ver ahora la ciudad está completamente
vacía no hay personas en la calle salvo
unos pocos jóvenes que hemos visto en
este camino la batalla continúa por el
asedio de esta ciudad sabemos que las
fuerzas ucranianas se enfrentan con las
rusas también en otras partes de la
ciudad ha habido edificios que han
sufrido importantes daños y con esto se
empieza empieza otro día difícil en la
capital de ucrania